hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting
to another kevin samuels clip before i
start do not forget
to like the video subscribe and hit that
notification bell
that way every time i post a video you
guys will be notified
okay let's see sorry i have like
i just ate like really spicy food and
i'm gonna be eating lunch during this
i'm just letting you know
it is what it is so let me make sure
this is definitely yeah
definitely yes you have any children i
do
i have a son mary single or not
definitely definitely definitely yes
you have any children i do i have a son
okay how old is he ten okay hello
uh how long are you with the child all
right my first impression
she has some masculine energy but she's
not as like
bad as some of the other people that
i've seen
um i'd say she's like somewhat
attractive like cute
okay like kind of average but like you
know what i mean like not bad
um that's just my first impression
though we'll see
i was with him for six years
are you divorced no we never got married
any particular reason why um it just was
a
it wasn't a healthy relationship another
toxic relationship
it was it i mean i got in it when i was
young
i know right it's like status quo
question
what do you think is young to get into a
relationship
i would say under the age of 21 is like
i was young
but i got into it when i was younger um
because i had my son at 26. he and i got
together
when i was 20 i'm shaking my hair
because i need you ladies to understand
how full of [ __ ] y'all sound you know
i'll come to the same toxic
relationships
no i'm not listening listen
y'all all sound full of [ __ ] to us when
you come in talking about a toxic
relationship that you were in for
multiple years
we don't believe you i agree i
understand
i get it so it wasn't a good situation
then why did you make a baby because
to be honest when you're because you
would have an unprotected sex oh god
two things
i think women get attached
when they have sex more than months um
like they call like pair bonding or
something and so i think it's a lot
harder for
like a lot of women will stay in bad
relationships because
they're just so like attached to this
guy if you weren't young
right 26 when i got pregnant correct
you weren't young which which i
understand
i'm not disagreeing with so what i'm
saying is what
so then why do it right
did you read did you listen to what i
just read about the woman
who was a single mother i did i did
so you
not necess every situation is this this
is what they wanted this is what they
want to believe
that yes that's for them but i'm special
no you're not me listen yeah
men on the open i don't really think
that she's really giving him attitude
market find out you have a baby
and they just say she's [ __ ] that
she's having sex
men look at you as a sex man look at
single mothers as sexual options
first and i don't care if you believe it
i don't care if you like it that's the
truth
i'm not disagreeing with you so that's
the point so
i'm saying this for you and for all the
other women if you choose to make
babies before you get married then
you decide that was a choice you made
okay
so you decided to do it you were having
unprotected sex you knew what you were
doing
right y'all could've went to the justice
of peace at any time in those six years
that you chose not to but why did you
choose not to
because it was a mentally emotionally
and i mean it was it was a bad situation
i got into the relationship
looking for nothing to be honest right
like how you've said before
when people um you don't know
you're not going you're not looking for
a husband right so i was just like out
there free willy-nilly
i wasn't looking for anybody so now that
aft
once i decided to leave the situation
was because
i knew exactly the why
right no it makes no sense to me as a
man
but you just decided to see if all this
would have been all right
as long as you didn't get pregnant which
i agree
i i'm sorry no so but i need you to
understand
that i was just out here do you guys
think that getting pregnant is like
a a choice or do you think that
accidents happen because some women are
like on birth control they still get
pregnant
do you think that that makes it even
worse because you knew you weren't
looking for anything seriously
why don't you allow yourself to get
pregnant and bring a kid into this
because
it's germaine to you're just why is this
important
because you're not looking for a husband
you're looking for a step
father at this point i'm
looking for a husband so i
i am do you have custody of your child i
do
then ma'am you're looking for a step of
course right
of course not at this point no no no
that's no no it is both
i am listening mother it's a stepfather
correct
correct first that's what he would be
okay
see that's what i mean ladies y'all just
play slick and losing i don't understand
that when a man sees you with a kid he
recognizes that that's a
package deal and i gotta take care in
the animal kingdom
what happens when the male of the
species
takes over a female with cubs from
with with offspring from another man
what happens to those offspring they
and i don't really know i don't know how
many animals either they have to go
under the ruling of the the guy
or they just get have get what tossed
into the wilderness i don't really know
i have no clue what do you think
they probably get tossed in the filter
yes that's tossed into the wilderness
man
that that man doesn't take that the cubs
so tossed into the wilderness means what
the outcome is what
that i mean i'm not i'm not really sure
think about it you're an intelligent
woman i'm going to say tossed into the
world
and there's no change in the wilderness
a cub into the wilderness what happens
to them kids die
to the to the cub then yes
he's so condescending sometimes like i
don't know what he's talking about it's
just on its own
it's on its own it's on its own really
it's on its own
until what until it gets
older and figures out god damn it
this is guys this and i'm doing this man
to just see if you're gonna say it
they're dead
it's not tossed on its own animals
who don't reach their majority don't all
of a sudden because you're a cub
and they just live they die right
do you know that do you understand or
just not want to say okay what does that
have to do
okay see like look it this is what
irritates me about kevin samuels this
woman
is saying look it i know i had a kid i
know
but in my opinion she's trying to ask
for advice
and he's just saying look you have a kid
die alone pretty but i mean he hasn't
said that yet but you guys get what i'm
saying like
i know a lot of blended families and
i'm obviously like if a guy's first
option
is going to be like a girl with no kids
totally fine but 80
of men are not talking to anybody
right that's the stat 80 of men are not
sexually active at all
there are probably guys she could talk
to maybe not like i guess we'll get into
her requirements but
it's just a little bit
um unsettling when i don't even think
she really came at him with an attitude
at all
hey no i get it but you didn't say it
because i didn't know where you were
going with that i said what happens to
with
a cub a kid on his own he said it's just
on its own until it grows up
i don't think you really want to do a
reality
that the reality is when a male of the
species in the mammal kingdom
takes over another woman he kills the
cubs
or they have to leave and take care of
themselves
and if they can't what happens to them
like you said they die right right and
we're mammals
men look at you with another person he
said damn
my money has to go to feed another man's
cub i don't want to do that
that's already competition your child is
always going to come
first to you that means a man
automatically knows he's going to come
second that's you're not looking for a
husband you're looking for a stepfather
you're looking for somebody to be a
stepfather who is willing
to not throw your child into the
wilderness that's willing to step into a
father and what is he going to get from
being such an incredible benevolent man
what is he going to get because you
didn't require the man who made the baby
to marry you
what are you going to give him that's so
great and wonderful that he's going to
get for saving you
your cup from the wilderness that's not
how y'all think about it
i mean i can get it i understand right
because there's
standards like there's the standalone
standard normal
and i understand like i'm not special
but then
i also know what i bring
to a table what is that i bring peace
like i'm able to bring peace so it's how
i bring peace
is your child bring peace my child does
break peace
and i actually as a boy or girl a boy
okay
um i hate to break this to you
that's the worst i'm one of the worst
situations to be in because boys
does he have a relationship with his
father no his father is not
has chosen not to be in his life that's
why he said it was a bad situation right
so well you picked him i did
and that's what irritates me about kevin
like she literally knows
kevin like she knows she's asking for
advice
like again i'm a very solution
oriented person so if i was going to
like talk to her and this is just
i'm not going to pretend that she should
come to me for like marriage and like
how to date advice
but i don't know go for a guy maybe that
doesn't make as much money
is really nice and maybe has kids of his
own you know
where i was at at that point in time i'm
not disagreeing with
a thing that you're saying that's
exactly right my point is
and the reason i'm doing this is because
women need to know
choosing to have a child for your
selfish reasons
costs you cost you suitable men
potentially no no no i mean no
no no they do it and we need to stop
lying you got to you get to you get you
get the men
who will pick you because they don't
have better options
i wouldn't say that though okay but this
is this is
the harsh like reality everybody
picks their best option right in terms
of compatibility
in terms of values and terms like you
don't date somebody unless that's
your best option
like you know what i mean like
that's and you know what and each
person's different and what they value
so men like tend to value one thing but
each guy is
different and i understand that she a
hundred percent
like threw chances at like suitable guys
away i'm not denying that at all
but my point is like kevin she gets it
like are you gonna help her of course
she would of course you wouldn't
of course you wouldn't but gentlemen if
you if you understand what i'm saying
gentlemen write down in the comment
section because this is
this is the level of disconnect see
women like yourself
think that i just had a baby and i'm
peaceful
and my kids good and perfect so we're
really not a bother
and men are just like i don't care what
you say that's
another man's kid and there's more food
i got to put out and
do you want to have any more children do
i want to i'm i am open to helping more
kids
you want so do you you're open so how
many more children could a man get from
you
i mean a couple more
for more a couple more kids so
understand that if a man had two
children with you
every time he put food in your child's
mouth
he's taking he's taking food out of his
other two kids mouth that's how our
minds think right
and i get it so so
so you ladies need to understand what
you bring that's so great and wonderful
because i'ma say this and it's gonna be
unpopular but single mothers
got to do far more than single single
moms got to do more than single women
because single women are looking for
husbands you're looking for stepdads
right and you try to seem like it's both
no it's a step dad
first because the man has to say i gotta
take that on
automatically that means on the day of
our wedding
this little crumb snatcher is gonna be
with us on our honeymoon
this crumb snatch is going to be waiting
for us i don't get one day with my wife
in my new home without this little crumb
snatcher being here
every day i'm there we got to worry
about this person
before he can get to me that's
men are territorial i get it yeah even
with their own
children right right right so
and if you had to pick between your
husband and your daughter
what you gonna pick my son your husband
or your son what you gonna pick
um i mean i would
i said your husband or your son what you
gonna pick
i would pick my husband if i'm married
it's my i grew up with my my
grandmother's still married i'm just
asking
yeah you wanna so if your husband so if
you're
so let's just say for sake of arguing
okay your son
becomes just irratible yeah and at 16
years old he's just the problem
and your husband says you need to put
him out
i mean if he can't shape up to be honest
you can't disrespect my husband
it's that simple it's that simple
and the reason i'm asking is because
women you need to ask yourself
questions that see it's interesting that
it's so
like black and white with them because
with my parents it was always a
compromise and they've been married for
a very long time
it was not just like whatever my dad
said said went
because because you like your son and
love your son
you ex you think that we don't look at
your kids that way
they're not assets to us they're all
liabilities yeah
and so the question becomes how do you
overcome
that when this woman overhears has no
kids you gotta over deliver
right so where
are you learning to oh where and this is
a conversation based upon how we got
here is because
you said you're looking for both a
stepfather and a husband i'm like yo
it's a stepfather first yeah
are you dating anyone have you dated
anyone seriously
since you had your child okay he's a
little bit less combative now kevin like
i think
he kind of went down a level because he
realized she was actually listening
yeah i have what's the launch
relationship you've had
since my son's dad almost years
almost two almost two years uh
and how was your son how old was he um
it ended last year
um so he was over three years old
yeah definitely yeah so why didn't when
you guys are in a monogamous community
relationship
we were but because i do understand
the element and the pressure of children
in a relationship
i don't introduce i don't bring that in
there right so he didn't meet your kid
he did not he did not meet my child
three years
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait yeah
it was long distance
so it really wasn't a relationship it
was
no it wasn't long-distance relationships
aren't real i get it
okay what so how long are you would you
do it okay you were with a man long
distance
for two years and he never met your son
my parents did long distance for two
years
i think so it wasn't it's not a real
relationship
i mean to each his own right but i can't
no it's not see this is like
creating their own reality and this
this is what okay kevin this is what
she's trying to say i'm gonna just give
it to you straight
she's trying to say that like it still
was a relationship
like it was it wasn't like there was
nothing if she was involved with a guy
for three years
but he's trying to say that it wasn't
like
a serious relationship so i think what
she's trying to say is it was a
relationship
he's saying it's not that serious that
he didn't even meet your kids
ma'am a real relationship implies you
live in the same place and you're close
enough to your late
long distance means you make a trip and
you have to be on your best for a short
period of time
so don't tell me to each his own because
you know there's a difference between
living
and and the reason i'm losing start
losing my patience is because you're 30
how old
i'm 36 does it sound like i'm talking to
a late teen early 20 something that's it
yeah then i'm sitting here trying to
tell you that
i really didn't think she was that bad
this relationship is not a real
relationship
but to each his own okay
you ain't even let nobody meet your kid
okay can your step would your stepfather
be able to would your husband be able to
discipline your side
would i allow that yes absolutely you're
just asking
yeah as anybody as anyone as any other
man ever discipline yourself
yes his father who what what
my first relationship like serious
relationship after
his father how long were you guys
together we were together in a short
time
it was he was coming out of a
relationship how long
honest he was coming out of america for
six months six it was like six seven
months it wasn't a long time and
how was your son at that time he was i
think three or four
uh and the guy you were with six months
had the ability to discipline yourself
not like spank them but like you know
hey
i guess redirect right that's not
discipline well
i i consider that to a point discipline
but
this is this is why this is so much
that's not discipline okay i get it but
yeah disciplining is what like
chastising right like that this one is
whooping his ass
right yeah he got to put food in his
open his stomach and the roof over his
head like he's his real daddy don't he
if i'm married correctly right so he
should be able to whoop his ass like
he's a real problem
yeah but my point but but but that's
easier said than done because
you've never know
that i do have with my child and it's
the conversation you do have with who
with with my child i mean he he
understands
firmly as to where i'm at with that and
so there's
so that's why i raise him a certain way
he's around family that ain't got
nothing to do with
another man well i which i get right but
ma'am you haven't had ma'am do respect
he's all theoretical with you
okay your son has not been around a man
long term he has none correct so you
don't know what you're going to do
and this is a problem you ladies just
talk like just because you believe
something that sounds good
that that's what's going to happen on
the ground your mama you ain't never had
to co-parent with nobody else what you
say go
your word is law and men
know this going into it especially if
they can hear what i've heard
date you for fun but marry somebody else
that
has less baggage because damn you don't
even
talk like a woman who is really
seriously preparing herself
to be a wife to somebody and having your
child
come under somebody look it you can see
in your face she's so offended
feels this discipline and structural
leadership like
why like how why you would say
i don't sound like because i i just
haven't heard
we haven't had that dialogue right as to
so she
i don't think it's that bad like she's
okay
what who's who you haven't had what
dialogue who's we
you and i damn i i can i i'm very good
at what i do
the questions i've asked i've been able
to glean quite a bit from your
the way you answer questions to each his
own
no man it's not
yeah you know i'm looking for a step up
and i'm looking for both
well you think it's you think you come
across as a woman who thinks that
because you and your son coexist in a
happy typical way
that a a man would come in and would
just be a bolt on and it would just be
automatic
that your son but i don't think that
though
i said you come across okay okay have
your son
your son is has never had to see
his mama well your two-year relationship
you didn't that boy didn't meet your uh
you're that man that's a problem
okay why didn't he meet him
for two years
i said well it was a while but yeah
it was it was intentional why is the
question
because of comfortability you know what
does that mean
i'm the kind of person that i like to
make sure that
whoever i'm dealing with is a hundred
percent comfortable
in a situation right so
and that's an element of bringing
someone some sort talk to me like i'm
four years old stop using all the big
words please just tell me why
big words yeah cause you're trying to
[ __ ]
no just say the truth well the truth i
mean that is the truth like if you're
not
necessarily comfortable and that's what
kevin
all she's saying is she did think the
guy that she was a date ache
would be comfortable meeting her kids i
don't think that's wise
but like i understand what she's saying
if you haven't dated somebody that
has children so he didn't meet you he
didn't meet your son because he wasn't
comfortable with your son
well no not that but he just hadn't
dated anybody that had that
that had children all right but fine you
were waiting for two years
right and then it is long distance
it's the same time so
not serious that's what i'm saying my
ultimate point is ma'am
there's so many red flags ding ding ding
ding ding ding
two years you said you dated somebody
you you were
monogamous supposedly and he didn't meet
your son that's a problem
i can introduce somebody but he didn't
meet your son
because he didn't want to meet him or
you weren't comfortable with having a
man around your son
that wasn't going to be your husband or
something no no it wasn't necessarily
that was it for him or for you
for me it was for everyone
right because i do think too much about
everybody
so i want him to be a hunter so your boy
your son knew you had a boyfriend
correct but he never met him correct
and he never wanted to meet him he did
he did mother son of a [ __ ]
yeah that situation isn't very wise
and did your boyfriend want to meet your
son
we never necessarily talked about that
it was always
for me saying whenever you're
comfortable with it again because it was
so
long distance and
i just wanted to focus on us building
our relationship
i asked a simple question did you want
to meet your son
at some point yes at what point
did you think that was going to be 10
years into it
no but definitely once it's like we're
gonna get engaged or
you know it's gonna progress to that
level so
i feel like there's difference that the
difference
okay and and this this conversation has
been a good example of why men don't
date single mothers seriously okay
this conversation has been taxing okay
and honestly women who don't have
children are far easier to get along
with because
i don't be concerned about all this
other stuff
and here's here's the problem and here's
the problem
i think it'll be easier to understand
that that's how men feel
if your child was a result of a loving
marriage and a child that was planned
it would be easier to accept that bitter
pill
but because your child was
unplanned
you compensate but men don't i mean you
have to compensate for that emotion
because you could at least say well yeah
you don't want to meet but me and her
dad were married
he has a man around he knew he was
playing
he hasn't your child doesn't know his
father right i've never met him
he has met him we were together for six
years yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
he met his father but how many kids does
his father have
um three how many different mothers
three yeah
yeah avoid this one damn avoid which one
me
you yeah do you you had it
yeah right yeah yeah because ma'am you
three children see
51 and i'm gonna tell you why i said
listen i'll tell you why this i don't
have three children no
listen oh 51
of black men are single in childhood 64
are in the middle class
fully fully 80
of the children of the black community
are made by by 18 of the men
damn i can agree with that and you knew
which baby mama were you number one two
or three number two okay but you knew he
had
one correct and you chose to have
unprotected sex with a man who already
had one
that puts you right in the rank of
another and men look at this men look
and say
that's dumb and now i look at it and say
that's dumb
i i agree so so me and look at it and
when me and when men
start running the cost benefit
calculator and say well let me let me
let me at least
delve a little bit into it all right you
were waiting for six years
but you didn't marry him because it was
toxic all right well
but meanwhile he had a kid by another
woman they got another kid
all right is he involved in his son's
life at all now no he's not he's chosen
he's chosen not to be involved all right
is he like a lawyer a physician or
construction did you go to college
i did i was in a different place in my
life at that point uh yeah okay
and you have a master's bachelor's
you cannot make this [ __ ] up i said now
masters still exists so a woman with a
masters has a kid by men with three kids
by three different women and no
disrespect to construction workers but
he's a construction worker
correct and you expect a man
of what a higher status around your
status
dwight women typically want men to have
on their level
meaning would you accept would you marry
a guy who's uh
an average earner making forty thousand
five hundred dollars for the rest of his
life
twenty dollars and twenty cents an hour
of his life yep those kind of men
even that's not what they asked that's
not what i asked would i marry
that kind of yeah if that's their
average earner
stay there i i would not so fully so
so don't so when people get mad at me
how am i talking to her i realized she
just
she just counted over 50 of black men
that's the needing income for a black
man in this country
she didn't ask about his character she
didn't ask about anything
and she just she just discounted him on
money so just because you can discount
me on money
listen listen listen listen listen
just like you can discount me on money
do you guys think that that says
something about your character though
this is
this is what i mean because as a girl if
i hear that a guy makes 45 55 like
whatever even 35 a year
right i don't care that does not matter
to me personally
what matters is that you're like doing
something and building something
and like you have a plan
because like i genuinely believe that we
have like a god-given
duty to do the best with what you got
like
it doesn't matter if you're that smart
doesn't matter if you're that like
whatever
you know um do the best that you can and
work hard at what you do
and to me if i hear that somebody's
making the same income
throughout their life especially as the
currency inflates you're actually making
less
year by year if you don't get a raise
to me i'm just thinking
he doesn't work hard and that's like a
trait that's really important
discount women like you based on your
past right true so
so so why i need what because but men
get a bad
rap for discounting right yes but y'all
but y'all
you didn't i just said money forty
thousand five hundred i said an average
earning black man right and you said oh
no
meaning you need an above average
earning black man
above average earning man period it's a
mindset
it's the [ __ ] that's what i was
saying
okay yeah
it means that you think your your value
is higher
because of your master's or whatever but
your value
i don't think my values are my masters
at all your socioeconomic position
no that's not why okay whatever man what
does money have to do with a mindset
then
so you can be you can be brilliant
and be a broke writer correct
so don't tell me about my money equating
to mindset
that's what i was saying like it doesn't
matter what you do to me
it just matters like if you're doing
something trying at it working hard
okay i mean i'm not gonna argue with you
my point my my point is i'm losing
patience because
i get upset when i hear women who are
average
looking over men who are average with no
compunction
but we are told that we are supposed to
y'all have no problem judging me like
that
and that's fine you can want what you
want and
she really hasn't been that judgmental
honestly
when he said her the salary i bet if he
said like
it'll go up 10 over time or something i
bet she would have been fine with it but
if you need a man who's above average
earner that's fine
that's fine if that's what you want
um are you earning in excess of six
figures
i've been around there all right so are
you so you would want your
prospective husband or man to be earning
around what you're making
i mean he could make a little less but
again a little less a little less
meaning what more than 75
75 is fine that's still the top 15 of
men
yeah damn those men are in
high demand okay
this is where it starts to get rocky
because
you're 36 you have a child
and your earning is up your your as you
as you get older your sexual marketplace
value decreases
but your income and your expectations go
up you're inversely proportional so a
man is making 75 000 or more
you can get a woman who is younger no
children
cooperative ready to be on this page and
all things being equal
what makes a better asset for that
potential man is that walmart
has room to make him number one not
coming second to a son
right and i and and kevin i understand
everything that you're saying
i don't i mean i don't think there's a
reason
i don't think that you don't just don't
understand it i just
i just don't understand that and men
would have to accept a lot with you
they'd have to accept one with me i have
to accept a lot no i
have to accept a lot they'd have to
accept a child
which is a lie that's a lot a lot
correct how tall are you
five eight and a half dress size i wear
size eight
okay a man would have to accept a lot
and the chances of having two additional
he's like
i just let me make sure you're thin
first don't you
pass 36 i mean
you you say you open to it but i'm
gathering that
if you don't have any more you'd be okay
i would like to have at least one
okay all right well the guy still has to
accept
a child whose father's not there right
and um and his siblings
as they stand right now come from one
two three different women
to us that's a lot and what is he going
to get
he gets a woman with the masters who's
earning six weeks but
men don't care about that stuff no and i
understand that so there's so much so
right so
why doesn't he just tell her what she
has to do
to become like a better fit the things
you say you bring
peace uh let's let's do this uh are you
a good cook
i am i'm actually a chef cool yes
so you have uh excuse me
do you own a restaurant do you want to
own a restaurant i own a catering
business i would love to own a
restaurant
it's a lot of work it is a lot of work
and that's why
i have a partner how many hours a week
are you putting in
how many hours a week do you put in um
and right i mean
we just started um my it's my cousin and
i are catering business
so with that right now hours wise might
be like 10 hours
5-10 hours a week a week and then i i'm
also i have a full-time job i'm a supply
chain manager and i work from home
as well you said you're a chef okay
i do i have you know dual career right
so i do two things
how many hours a week are you working
i'm on my
period man period period
probably i might put in 40 45 hours a
week
so your full-time job isn't 40 hours
it it is but i have systems and stuff in
place where
i don't i can i i kind of disperse my
time
yeah so sounds like many professional
women
your life is humming along in a single
fashion
what do you mean uh you got a job
you got a side job or a business you
have a son
um you make enough money to where you
really don't have to never man i mean
so there's really no sense of urgency to
really
understand who men are what they want
i mean i said there's no sense of
urgency correct okay i can okay
i get it because it and what i'm saying
is
some of the things i've been saying if
if you really understood who men are and
what they wanted
there shouldn't really be any pushback
with some of the things i'm saying
or everybody's different or no special
snowflake or
i mean and and the biggest portion is to
recognize
that the likelihood of meeting a man
who is a top 15 top 10 top five
percent earner and your age
your is
slim i've met them though
so like seriously yeah
though lady why are you on a show why
don't you ask him
what can you do like
i'm like why are you here so it's not
but i understand
in general let me go ahead and further
clarify
i don't mean meet deal with hook up i
mean because being vetted by
being seriously being vetted as a wife
yeah yeah guess what
yes like i don't know what yes means i
mean yes as in that's
i have no no no you had just
you mean oh no no although i want to be
clear are you trying to say
that you've met you have men that are
actively vetting you to be their wife
correct and how long have you been
seeing these men
for i mean i've been
dating for the past like six months now
how many different men how many
different men um right now
i've got two pretty good options
they're both long distance um no
so you're saying that you have okay well
if that's the truth you're saying that
two men
are ready to marry you they're vetting
me
so much yeah we're betting each other so
now i know well just because again like
and i understand why you ask the
questions that you do
and why you say the way because it is in
the general sense right but without
no it's not really because men who are
uh now
men who are marriage minded typically
don't allow themselves to be vetted but
don't put themselves in a position where
they're in a lottery with a couple other
men
wait not lottery i'm not calling it a
lottery but i
i mean okay i misunderstood what you
said for a second if i'm dating
i agree with what he said
no when i say vetting that means a man
is looking for a wife
and there are men who are looking for
wives ready to get married know what
they want they typically make a move in
under six months
right that's what i mean you ladies
called but it's very common like
i have very common i know a lot of girls
that dated a guy for like
two three years and then ended up
getting married like that's almost
typical in this day and age i understand
like people with his
like traditional mindset but i i
definitely disagree with him
that um
good like i'll give you an example my
brother he makes he's above average in
terms of like earning right
and he dated he like
lives with his girlfriend whatever and i
asked him i was like so when you're
gonna like
put a ring on it you know because i love
her like she's great and he literally
just told me
whenever she annoys him about it and
this is my brother like
obviously i'm biased but he's a good guy
he makes good money
he works hard he's a good boyfriend like
i i see this all the time so i disagree
with him
i'm sure when you're older it's
different though things things that men
don't call them
no i said i was i was i'm dating i said
i said
i know what i said you said you had me
and they were actively betting you to be
a wife
right that means that typically means
that's a monogamous one-on-one you got a
a serious relationship you men don't bet
somebody
that they're not committed to or
involved with so also
i'm i guess culturally i'm not american
either so it's it's different
from a cultural perspective how long
have you lived in america
i mean for a long time to knock off the
[ __ ]
no it's not kevin
let's don't start the whiny girl stuff
am i doing the whiny girl voice okay i
mean i i think that
she's flirting with him
well i'll say this okay that um
one of the big problems today with
modern women is you guys are overly
optimistic about reality
and you can believe
[Music]
not i mean somebody has to win the
lottery
uh but okay this is what i don't like
about that logic somebody has to win the
lottery like
this is what guys will do especially in
the manosphere this irritates me
their argument is like oh you found an
exception to the rule
but it's mostly like this or whatever
and i hear what they're saying but like
you could have that attitude with
anything
you can have the attitude like making
money is hard making money is impossible
like i'm just i'm a solution minded
person
um the way you're saying talking is
though do you have
are you saying that one of the you're
going to marry one of these
potentially yes
says no potentially um
all right
so are these men earning on your level
of higher
yes so you mean that you got this man
and that men both earning on your level
higher and you got two of them and
there's only one of you
i'm dating kevin
damn he was done
she got she did get more annoying as the
thing went on girls never give like real
answers to anything
i get i do that sometimes too women like
to talk
men like to be direct and get the answer
so
like if you ask a guy like how was
dinner a guy would say
good it was fun or whatever and a girl
would be like oh it was so good
until like three stories anyways let me
know in the comments if you think that
if if you think she was annoying or if
you thought that she really
she'll find someone i don't know and
don't forget to subscribe
hit that notification bell ring the bell
i'll talk to you guys
next time